[Music]
hi I'm Toby Terrence and I am so excited
to be here amongst Royals and sci-fi
royalty for the release of Star Wars the
last Jedi in London what's even more
exciting is that for one night only IMAX
has transformed the iconic Royal Albert
Hall into a completely immersive IMAX
theater
[Music]
we have got an enormous IMAX screen
custom sound system to IMAX xenon
projectors the whole package in order to
give everyone a once-in-a-lifetime
viewing experience of this epic film the
screen is roughly the size of eight
tennis courts seventy eight feet wide 27
feet tall and the imax xenon projection
system consists of two giant projectors
weighing an incredible 2,600 pounds
combined a truly incredible feat that
only IMAX could pull off for this very
special night and it brings us all here
to the red carpet I am so excited before
we go inside and watch the last Jedi I'm
gonna speak for the light and the dark
side about what's in store oh man
the last Jedi is just about that the
defining fight between good and evil
with general lair at the helm and kylo
Ren coming into his own what happens
when darkness the light that's the last
year though each character faces
challenges that they never would have
expected I might have put a massive
screen in there and a incredible sound
system joked I'm so excited
I've never been to the Royal Opera at
all so I'm looking forward to it very
anxious to see what it looks like this
sounds like it shows I think a genuine
love and affection for the Star Wars
franchise you know it gets me very
excited at the movies finally
I've never been to anything like this
before being here feels overwhelming I
can't believe two years as par since the
last time we were here I think people
should be ready for a few surprises
should be open to those surprises big
action seems to farm the adventure the
ride and I think fans are gonna have to
go see this maybe more than once so that
is it from me I'm off to be transported
to a galaxy far far away
I am very excited now don't forget to
book your IMAX tickets you don't to be
the last Jedi to get them
for Phil
destiny
[Music]
[Music]